[Applauso]
[Musica]
chi di voi
in un momento di difficoltà è mai stato
aiutato da un amico
chi invece ha aiutato un amico che era
in difficoltà chi magari non ne ho avuto
l'occasione ma aiuterebbe un amico se si
trovasse in difficoltà
benissimo vedo con piacere che siete in
tanti purtroppo però non è sempre
possibile aiutare un amico un caso in
cui non è possibile è quello in cui
l'amico in questione soffre di disturbi
alimentari ma non è possibile ma non è
che non è possibile perché manchino
manchi la voglia di farlo ma perché
manca mancano gli strumenti
ora però fermi un attimo probabilmente
avete sentito la parola disturbi
alimentari e qualcuno sta già pensando
ok anoressia bulimia adesso ci proietta
le immagini di qualche ragazza
scheletrica e ce ne andiamo tutti a casa
un po angosciati e senza avere imparato
nulla di nuovo
no non è il mio intento non sono uno
psichiatra
penso si veda e non ho mai sofferto di
disturbi alimentari
quindi cosa vengo a fare oggi vi vorrei
parlare dell'aspetto relazionale cioè di
come ci si può comportare con chi ha un
disturbo alimentare o meglio di come io
ci ho provato a un'amica che soffre di
anoressia da circa due anni e in questo
tempo io varie volte avrei voluto che
qualcuno mi dicesse cosa fare e cosa
dire come comportarmi
perché io volevo relazionarmi con lei ma
mi sentivo estremamente inadeguata
perché mi mancavano gli strumenti e
questo fin da quando l'ho scoperto
infatti quando lo si scopre da un lato
ci sono la paura e l'apprensione per una
persona a cui si tiene ma dall'altro
si realizza che quella persona non la si
conosceva per niente perché pensavo se
la conoscessi veramente me ne sarei
accorta prima e qui si insinua un senso
di colpa perché mi illudevo che se me ne
fossi accorta prima l'avrei potuto
aiutare ad ogni modo con qualche amico
ci siamo detti che l'importante per
aiutarla da quel momento in avanti
quindi dato che era ricoverata ma siamo
andati a trovare in ospedale
la prima volta c'erano tutti ma
successivamente qualcuno ha smesso di
venire e non bisogna fargliene una colpa
perché hanno smesso
beh un po è perché il reparto dei
disturbi del comportamento alimentare
visivamente fa impressione quindi
qualcuno fa fatica entrarci passarci
pomeriggio
ma poi perché le persone non sanno come
comportarsi appunto
ed è lì che ho capito che non era solo
un problema mio che è perfettamente
normale sentirsi inadeguati in queste
situazioni la primissima volta che la
siamo andati a trovare una mia amica per
rompere il ghiaccio ha chiesto se
avrebbero portato la merenda anche a noi
perché hanno i pasti assistiti un'altra
ragazza capendo che forse non era
proprio la cosa migliore da dire in quel
frangente ha pensato bene di cambiare
discorso domandando come mai tutte le
finestre del reparto erano chiuse a
chiave
ora tutti noi abbiamo un influenza sulle
altre persone piccolo grande che sia
positiva o negativa che sia
ce l'abbiamo tutti e di conseguenza
siamo tutti un po plasmati da chi ci
circonda
quella visita forse non è stata
totalmente piacevole ma se non ci
fossimo andati la mia amica sarebbe
stata peggio quando ha visto entrare
dieci persone dalla porta del reparto
era contenta per questo oggi vi voglio
parlare di come relazionarsi perché se
dobbiamo avere un'influenza facciamo sì
che sia positiva
quello che vi vengo
quello che vi vengo a raccontare oggi è
un po come io ho cercato di reagire
perché non facciate i miei stessi errori
e quello che ho imparato prima ascoltare
questo vale un po sempre nella vita se
non si sa cosa fare è la scelta migliore
però non ascoltare solo per poi poter
rispondere e neanche ascoltare e
pensando di potersi immedesimare perché
vi dico subito che non ci si riesce
e neanche ascoltare pensando di sapere
già o ascoltare per compatire ma
ascoltare perché ti interessa cosa da
dire l'altro una diretta conseguenza è
il non fare finta che non ci sia nessun
problema perché questi disturbi sono
espressioni di disagi più profondi
se noi non diamo la possibilità di
esternarle in altro modo chi ne soffre
continuerà esternarli tramite la
malattia sembra una cosa facile
ascoltare ma non è per niente perché i
disturbi alimentari sono disturbi
psichiatrici e come tutti i disturbi
psichiatrici fanno un po paura viene
d'istinto isolare la persona evitare di
parlarne ma in questi casi bisognerebbe
mettere da parte le proprie paure
forse anche il proprio egoismo per dare
spazio a passioni più positive secondo
se non dobbiamo evitare l'argomento
bisognerebbe però evitare di parlare
solo di cibo peso e diete per quanto
riguarda il cibo non è un problema a
mangiarli davanti però non obbligata a
mangiare perché non è totalmente una
questione di volontà
se sul momento mangia è per farvi
smettere di insistere però non funziona
veramente
per quanto riguarda il peso invece
evitare i giudizi
per quanto possa sembrare contro
intuitivo anche i complimenti perché
creano molta confusione
una cosa che personalmente mi era
sfuggita è quella di evitarli anche se
sono rivolti ad altri vi faccio un
esempio delle mie compagne di classe
stavano prendendo in giro un'altra
ragazza
tra l'altro usando espressioni anche
abbastanza forti della serie è una
balena e la mia amica in seguito mi ha
confessato di aver avuto una piccola
erika
per quei commenti che non solo aveva
sentito per caso ma che non erano
rivolte a lei sono invece ammessi dei
commenti legati alla cura della persona
quindi complimenti sul trucco sui
capelli sui vestiti se li pensate
davvero e soprattutto non legati al peso
alle forme corporee
terzo punto non creare aspettative
provo a spiegarmi meglio la mia amica
sempre avuto ottimi voti a scuola un
giorno viene da me e dal nulla mi dice
sai chiara
penso di non voler fare l'università vi
ricordo di averla guardata scandalizzata
e di averla quasi aggredita come non
vuoi fare università poi non sai cosa
fare della tua vita
questo è sbagliatissimo avrei dovuto
sostenerla
magari se non ero d'accordo con la sua
scelta a chiedere il perché ma non
cercare di imporre una mia aspettativa
su di lei
nel frattempo volevo scoprire qualcosa
di più sui disturbi alimentari però
capivo che la mia amica non poteva dirmi
tutto allora fatto qualche ricerca in
modo autonomo letto qualche libro da
queste mie ricerche ho scoperto il
quarto e ultimo punto non cambiare tutto
in funzione della persona che soffre di
disturbi alimentari come mai un
meccanismo frequente però inconscio in
chi soffre di disturbi alimentari e non
volersi curare per l'idea che altrimenti
amici e familiari non ti amano più come
si fa ad arginare questo meccanismo ad
esempio contesto scolastico è
controproducente far saltare una gita
perché il ragazzo la ragazza in
questione non può partecipare oppure
contesto familiare situazioni come il
classico cenone di natale abbiamo detto
non obbligata a mangiare quindi
effettivamente non fatelo lasciate
mangiare un po meno al ragazzo la
ragazza o lasciate di mangiare qualcosa
di più leggero però non cambiate il menu
apposta lasciate gustare tortellini e
pandora ai familiari
un altro esempio ancora prima abbiamo
detto ascoltate i loro problemi
sì giustissimo però non fate solo quello
ridete con loro divertitevi con loro
anzi a volte raccontategli anche dei
vostri di problemi come in tutte le
amicizie
perché io mi sto preoccupando tanto di
vivi come ci si comporta
però in fondo se ci fate caso ci si
dovrebbe comportare così così si
dovrebbe comportare come con tutto il
resto degli esseri umani ascoltare e non
giudicare perché questo che sono persone
hanno una malattia certo ma non solo la
loro malattia ed è compito degli amici
ricordarglielo perché è vero i disturbi
alimentari come abbiamo già detto sono
disturbi psichiatrici gravi
alcune ragazze arrivano alla morte e chi
riesce a uscirne comunque ci mette anni
si porta dietro le conseguenze per tutta
la vita ma ribaltiamo per un attimo la
prospettiva la maggioranza di chi si
ammala non muore di anoressia si può
riuscire emanciparsi dalla malattia
sì ci vogliono tantissimi anni ci vuole
fiducia in chi ti cura ci vuole il
supporto appunto degli amici e familiari
ci vuole tantissima forza di volontà ci
vuole pazienza però è possibile è
possibile smettere di identificarsi con
la malattia o è possibile continuando ad
averla riuscire a vivere una vita più
che soddisfacente ma per fare questo è
indispensabile l'aiuto degli amici
perché nessuno esce da solo da un
disturbo psichiatrico
mi è piaciuta molto una frase di una
psichiatra specializzata e nella cura
dei disturbi del comportamento
alimentare e marta scoppetta lei ha
usato questa espressione il ruolo che
dovrebbe avere un amico in questi casi è
di remare con il doppio dei remi invece
di remare in senso contrario
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]